Leslie is in Boston hi Leslie how are
you yeah I deserve it you got your
tickets to smart conference next weekend
I do I'll see you I'm looking forward to
being up there with you guys how can I
help today alright so I am anybody stop
follower I love this if it works for me
I'm debt free now and so I'm just
spreading the message you know I want to
change the family tree so I've been
trying to inspire my younger brother
than younger cousins and as I'm talking
about finances with the more I I
discovered that money answers as you
would say financially abusing my cousin
she's taking our cards credit cards out
of college and making out checks and her
name because I cut is so bad that she
can't she can no longer do that on her
and you know I see how sad and I don't
know what could be because it's you know
someone older than me it's my aunt my
mom's sister but it's my youngest cousin
and I feel like I have an obligation to
her to hold it hold it younger cousin
she's 16 years old in high school okay
so and this is that your aunt's your
aunt's is child yeah are you are there
any does your are your parents your page
your parent that is her brother or
sister still around
my parents my both of my parents are
still around it's my mother sister okay
so what would your mother say if she
found out that your aunt was abusing her
kid so I talked to her about it I felt
like it was the right thing to do this
is really uncomfortable but she said you
know we have to get her the closing
accounts because I just found out that
she has I think $2,000 Justin fees
and the car it only has like a few
months on it yeah but I mean your mother
is the one needs to confront or not you
okay
her sister yeah she's gotta say this is
ridiculous
you're messing up your own kid what's
wrong with you okay so I shouldn't take
this on my own what about my cousin and
should I talk to her yeah is this your
other cousin has an older sibling no
she's an only child also it's a
different cousin a different a different
parent a single family home her father's
not around yeah but they have one kid
the lady the aunt that's screwing over
her own kids there's one good okay so
does your mother and her sister have any
other siblings they don't live on
this-tv okay well your mom and your dad
need to go over there and sit down with
your mom's sister and say quit abusing
your own child if you want to go with
them you can but you're your aunt is
much more prone to listen to her sister
than to you mm I would hope so but she
doesn't hear there's the thing if you
don't stop this you're going to jail
because we're going to take you to the
cops actually told her that one time
yeah and she's still doing it well then
take her to the cops if she was beating
the crap out of the kid would you just
stand there and watch her do it no no
that's what she's doing she's destroying
a 16 year old
somebody's got to care enough to stand
in the gap here and it's not this is not
okay this is not a lightweight thing
she's screwing up a kid's life so yeah
you guys got a bust on her and if she
doesn't stop you need to say listen if
you'll stop we're gonna have you put in
jail
stop hammer put in jail I'll get her
attention give her some dadgum bracelets
that connect she's screwing her own kid
this is unbelievable
you guys ought to be are irate you ought
to be busting her chops this is
ridiculous
yeah you guys get you this is not a
difficult but she she's abusing her
child I don't care if it's difficult you
guys you and your mom and your dad need
to be over there like this week saying
here here's a plan for you do not pass
go go directly to jail or close these
accounts and never do this again if I
ever see you ever so much as think about
opening an account in anyone's name that
is not your name I will report you for
identity theft this is criminal freakin
fraud it's criminal fraud it's a federal
offense to steal someone's identity
you know and then to do it to your own
kid it's just trash it's unbelievable
so yeah listen I don't care for a little
feelings or hurt or not you guys need to
go hurt her feelings
soon because there's a child's life at
stake here her financial life this kid
could spend the next decade of her life
trying to straighten this out and at 22
23 24 years old is struggling with the
emotions of the fact that her mother is
scum and while she's trying to clean up
this mess yeah you guys got to get all
righteous about this there's no way
around it Leslie light them up man just
light them up it's just so wrong there
are to be some righteous indignation
around this